you
this guy smacked me around the last few
times we played this is vety 14 has a
very high very high blitz rating like
ballpark 2800 I believe alrighty let's
do it
something something faster than
something much faster than a puzzle okay
we get in there I know now we're just
going to centralize maybe expand on the
queenside see what they do sneak in a
flight square I'll take with the night I
think I want to play within this
structure Knight to d5 supporting get at
the C 7th on their queen can't feel too
comfortable
I don't think what's that not going to
do oh I'd even realize that a the bishop
can take there now I want to force them
to take me being very stubborn though ok
now I have something I could try to buy
tap d6 my winning
on I think so
I'm winning more than the fondo because
that's check I don't like the technique
I'm using ooh
I like that move I could manage this one
I'm pretty sure
this is a very tough opponent happy to
happy to win this one I think I'm going
to win this one
I was ready to stalemate there I think
back to tournament
that was a game of inches let me tell
you
Meddy very very tough guy tough opponent
oh I don't know we're gonna try
nimzo-indian land and playing a lot of
iran do here I've been playing a lot of
the old Indian so we're going to change
it up though
alright now maybe we hunt down that c4
pawn he's a weakling how is he going to
be defended
Knight to d2 does it
pawns on dark ah maybe I try to get an
e4 they stopped that cold alright
they're going to go with f4 it seems
like the only decent pawn break my night
I know for Queen on g5 and made on g2
yeah they're not sure what to do I'm not
sure how much progress I could really
make either g3 rook f2 is not going to
cut it
a think tank I just got made it they
didn't see the to me berserk only is
there true to his name really I didn't
know that he was a well he didn't always
have that little bit I don't know - he
um
yeah Jamaica huh I guess -
I always have that wasn't always posted
the country anyhow let's go fishing how
about it's been a while since I did that
are they going to go Queen side let's
take what the pond oh I'll try a little
jab at h2o
okay they're still showing the ref on
down huh this night is going to be a
monster and a half no I think the bishop
careful now we got a Megan to threat I
went here instead of e7 they're ready to
block on h3
you know let's block here that's why I
went here in case the the bishop went
there oh I have to be really careful
there's Bishop takes pawn ideas that
what they're chewing them yeah look at
lunch setting that up sneaky sneaky
sneaky sneaky let's just defend threats
I think I have everything covered um I
don't know let's just go here Knight is
poison
I could have captured that pawn let's do
it now I think my king has had enough
he's going to run away and let's just
contest this file now I have a bit of a
time edge
okay here I guess their evening up with
the clock there I don't like that I'm on
g2 I'm on g2 I could do this I have a
chi seven I can run to a little scary
but with the little calculation we're
all right we're golden
now they're being sneaky a time burner
I had enough gas though just enough gas
and then on the clock
then I had to say that I had to say that
on the ticker all right we got 20
minutes left here berserk only is in the
lead with an insane 21 Wow
all right we're still going to go
fishing we didn't catch anything in that
first game
yeah everybody I don't know everybody is
up they know how to defend they do that
little bishop maneuver and sometimes
just go Queen side and say how you
getting at my a my King now
ideas scaring me it's probably still
good actually let's defend against c5
push I'm going to play out four and now
let's just try to kick him around giving
this square up
here I guess well
a big fight for the dark squares Oh
let's take here yeah cuz I'm on this
point and he's going to hang around here
so things are fine now let's scoop him
up I'm on the brook and it's just
improved let's move forward and go fast
go forward and do it fast there in the
think tank get a flight Square in there
happy to see that oh that is a queen
let's just trade I have a passed pawn
pushing him right now I'll take him
I'm getting a queen very soon can't be
stopped all right we got pins every
which way
night is pins and they're down on time
all right 18 in change
26 is number one berserk only
okay yeah and that's a that's a 2300
rated Berserker yeah I'm not sure what
my rating would be if I only berserk not
very high okay watch out watch out for
f2 we don't want to get mated you take
me and you're just going to return so
that's my flight square what are you
doing what's this infatuation with f2
men you need to stop that right now
rat badger go away bishop
um I really do not enjoy this kind of
pressure I feel like let's just go
queenside you want to take off to do it
it's probably a good move playing a
little hope chess here I'm just afraid
of these sacrifices if I went that way
get out of there go away I'll take here
now you're taking up too
okay I
position here they're just going in the
packet you're going to take here that's
going a little too crazy okay I actually
MRI in this end game I believe and I say
that only with an eye on the clock I'm
going to win on time that's my
prediction I'm going to I'm going to
time burn my way to victory let's just
get ready to the tricky guy see there
they gone a little slower that's all you
have to do when on time is fine just
drop here no time
the rat badger
that Queen h4 move I don't know holy cow
berserk only you need to slow down man
36 all right this guy if he beats me in
berserk mode it would not be the first
time lightning quick and you're getting
to see it in action right now oh that's
a little stumble a little Stumbler let's
household before we get hit with an
accident here on the e-file can we take
advantage of the pin we're going to try
you still pinned I think he's a goner
we're going to trade I can handle this
I hope my technique is good enough we
got some stability for the night and we
March these puns watch out for any
trickiness there's something that's part
of the trickiness I'm talking about all
right they resigned back to tournament a
little speed bump there for berserk only
but yo they have a 30 36 on there
that's on pace for like whoa 70
territory huh 27 minute tournament
again
by the Titan who remembers this guy
anybody I haven't stopped
bad jokes it didn't end after that that
time I got scholars made it it's another
bad joke whoo that's a pond and a bad
structure now the OL Rover technique
who's a fan of the rover technique the
rook up and over Rover this game I tell
you this game is kind of I don't know Oh
careful now
that's a fork that's a dangerous pun I
don't wanna come after my bishop my
knight wants to play my bishop wants to
be saved
oh boy pushing through I'll take with
the sneaky Knight take stuff I didn't
promote right away
you have pawns you could still move I
don't have to fear stalemates got it
back to tournament
13 minutes left
uh 36 24 18 18 16 16 okay why don't we -
II for Best Buy test a French huh
a French tirage oh that's how you want
to play it huh Muntz pink fur let's just
think as long as we as I did with that
last puzzle huh
let's just spend all day unmoved what -
okay we'll take now only after he moved
once come on it took me forever to make
that move I backed up because I want to
keep I want to keep pressure off of that
I want to be able to do this very thing
this very thing and threaten me I will
gladly do this in now anchor knight on
e4 this is a stable square once the
planters are pitching some pawns here my
knight is super
into a pin my nights going to do
something magical though no
oh what's that about No oh that worked
out really well
yes I love pawn takes pawn takes rook
moves one of my favorite moves on takes
Knight a backbreaker oh there's a lot of
heat on that d4 square watch out for the
sneaky mate watch out for the sneaky
mate we're close to a sneaky mate night
g3 I control g1 my rooks excited to
control these three and we're going to
end the end hit them with a fork
pick up the exchange and I'm going to
drop a bishop not quite I'm I love that
f5 squares so much my other Knight wants
to be there it's just such a good square
we'll take what the pawn right about now
exchange oh they have a queen check
there we're gonna we're going to try to
back rank me that's a serious thorn
right there okay rook do something
constructive I have this move let's do
it right now let's just break things
down let's save him these guys aren't
going anywhere they got rid of my
annoying pawn I wanted to stop the
knight from even going there
defend a seventh rank let's mop up
another pawn
now you're going Knight you have hit me
with the fork one too many times you
just you gotta go and now my rook is in
a perfect spot to just keep on advancing
ah time burner is not going to shave off
20 seconds in that position forty two
thirty two twenty two is where we're at
Plus this guy you'll come
an advanced caro-kann i'll run home and
say that this is a long-term issue we go
it's g5 a lot of players go it's g5
there I don't think it's right
I'll take there I want to have some
square to play with I could end up
getting a suffocated if I don't do that
d5 is mine
I want some trades ooh I got to be
really careful yeah if I took like this
does a check that's scary so we're going
to go with the less scary stuff now
unfortunately I have to always worry of
this pawn push they should seek a light
square bishop exchange that's what
they're going with yeah this is tough
this is
a tough one to play okay I don't mind
seeing that okay they're going to
challenge my queen I believe that Bishop
is getting way too active
maybe my queen could turn into pac-man
okay there's one there's two
vii though cropland to of
the best great strategy push this pawn
he's passed keep pushing let's get a
little trade going on
push the past pawns
change plans let's just hunt him down
and offer a queen exchange we're going
to get that okay deflection got enough
time and getting a clean run like the
wind blows mop up the last ponds no
stalemates please maybe we get three
Queens check make it pretty okay back to
term I had a few seconds left forty
berserk only slipped up again but still
has a beefy 47
um his in the game right now against a
tough guy yeah that he might he might
flip up again that guy he's playing
against is really strong really strong
it's 2,500 monster 2500 plus
you know this bullet rating I haven't
committed my king let's go clean side
grab some Tempe against their Bishop in
a backup ok I gotta get my King out of
here let's control the c5 break which is
the only a pawn break I really have to
fear Bishop here might be an idea let's
get to the G file first Bishop f5 and
they could kick me away I could push
efore let's just play with you for g6
maybe e5 now I could take the knight and
then push the knight should return to
help defend this square he's not um I
don't want to drop him play into c5 next
with east 6 they should be crushing ok
the Knights at least there to help
defend against that um ok I can't avoid
that exchange actually ok so let's just
get on with it and my king whoa glad I
was not in pre-move mode there man the
knight moves there's a big problem well
he has to move they're in a pickle he's
either gone it's either the night of the
rook that's going to be cooked
48:40 29 he ended up drawing that game
Wow
again okay we're eight back five minutes
to go let's see how this finishes up
just a few more games left see if we
could stay on pace here keep the streak
going
could use a quick win it's going to be
hard to pull off against this guy but
we're still going to try um I really
wanted to maybe just take their
straightaway I could now though right
ooh quick resigner
quick resigner no quick designer stay
here
to my night
let's scare that night away what is
going on giving me pieces it's very
difficult it's very difficult to deal
with this night
I am up a full queen in this position
I will definitely give some material
back no problem with that I could have a
captured here yeah I had some kind of
mate
around g2 now let me check
why I'm playing it like this I should
have captured an h6 there's this pin
going on here
can we just trade a rook that's all I
want to do trade a rook and then enter
and now you have to be feel that's just
made on the spot great 48 you definitely
have my chances 4844 I have fire he's in
a game against another tough guys ìbut
videos 353 left 184 in this one
okay play something simple they're going
with a very solid system and let's see
if we could sneak in b5 we can in time
fish up here on the e6 and I'll prisoner
I was going to preserve my bishop given
an opportunity but
okay they're not allowing that they're
going to get their break in
let's play this
move a very bad move maybe they take and
then I get there okay yeah this is not
working out how I would like it to work
out
um can I take here
pawn rook takes Knight rook down that
seems like it's working that cost a lot
of time though that's going to come back
to bite me
probably can I hang on to that pond it's
not looking like it they're going to
hunt him down with Knight to d1
hmm
probably not the best what I'm doing
here huh oh I didn't even see that my
rooks under fire that's bad news
gotta go faster much faster they're
going to try to cut off my rook
Oh need him around not looking good can
I leave a mate I have a dangerous night
dangerous night man can he do something
they had mate I'll die could take my
night ah they're gonna make me ouch
they had that a move sooner I think as
well spoiled my hopes
4844 ah maybe I should have reserved my
my bishop
instead of
instead of playing a six in that
position
okay so we have a benoni all right let's
try for rook G 1 and G 4 yeah play is
going to go over towards the Kings side
here let's just give him a shove
upon like whenever like whenever
get rid of this best piece what am i
rooks doing on the G file could somebody
tell me
they're doing nothing
and let's stop there one
on break
they have one pawn break if I move my
king here they would have captured yeah
let's just duck these uh these threats
and put my rooks here and we're going to
push push next let's do it keep pushing
and take with the night maybe and now I
could take here
I could still take there
not anymore I'm down on time and we got
some material and we're going to we're
going to get some more here I guess
let's just get rid of the night plenty
of time now stalemates and I get this
last one it's not counting for the
tournament let's just get him out of
here
skip pawns away who needs them right
you
I took war
too long to get that last one
but I still like it was possible that I
would know I was only I would have had
48 he was still going to take first but
hmm I spent too much time on that game
that I lost
okay berserk only took that 151 whoops
5144 39:31 is where we stand
190 players in all you tough a tough
crew here this is one player I didn't
get paired up with very good player
this one to my last opponent played many
many many times
okay to the 189 of you good games all
you